Ce message nous demande de rembourser un emprunt qu'on a fait à la banque de fer.
Qui est, accessoirement, la banque la plus dangereuse du Royaume.
Avec eux, les mystères sont pas de mise.
Là, si on rembourse pas...
Bon voilà, on a plus un sou, bye bye le trône de fer.
Et le budget papier toilette va être serré ce mois-ci.
Va falloir retourner dans les douves.
On a suivi les conseils stupides de Lord Peter.
C'est vrai, emprunter de l'argent aux banquiers les plus dangereux du monde...
C'était mon idée.
Mais pas les rembourser...
Ça, ils l'ont trouvé tout seuls.
Mes fidèles compagnons.
C'est une journée...
Très, très difficile pour moi.
Alors je dois vous annoncer que, malgré tous nos efforts...
Nous ne prendrons jamais la tête du Royaume.
Ok.
On a terminé ?
Parce que je suis invitée à manger de la viande.
Non, non, non, attendez...
Pourquoi on a pas droit au trône ?
Parce que la banque de fer nous a tout pris.
On a plus rien.
Donc soit on a une sorcière, soit on a un fils de dragon.
Je suis un fi...
- Un vrai !!!
Un vrai, un vrai bordel, avec des papiers.
Y a pas de papiers.
Mais je suis un fils de dragon !
Les fils de dragon, ils ont les cheveux dorés.
Y a eu beaucoup de mariage entre nous et les gens du Sud.
Oui mais c'est pas une preuve ça !
Ok.
Tu veux une preuve ?
Ouais.
Vous voulez une preuve ?
- Je t'en supplie.
Ouais.
- S'il te plait.
- Je t'en supplie.
Ouais.
- S'il te plait.
Je demande un bûcher !
Trop théâtral.
Non pas trop théâtral.
Trop théâtrale c'est : Je demande un bûcher.
Sinon, je connais une sorcière...
Non !
Donc, gens de maison, vous allez nous faire un bûcher, s'il vous plaît.
Un bûcher.
Oui.
Mec, si tu touches à mes pions...
Oh putain, je vais le défoncer...
Si il a du sang de dragon, il est censé résister au feu.
Mais moi, je pense qu'il va plutôt se cramer la gueule.
J'ai rien dit parce que j'adore les activités en plein air.
Pour vous prouver, à tous !
Que je suis bien un fils de dragon.
Je vais me jeter, dans un bûcher de feu !
Pléonasme.
Allumez.
Bon, pour l'instant ça va.
Ça va.
Ah... Ah non !
Je brûle !
Je brûle ! Aidez-moi !
Ah !
Aaaaaah ! Attendez !
Attendez...
Non, ça va en fait.
Juste une petite sensation de...
Brûlure ! Aaaah !
Ma jambe brûle !
Tout mon corps brûle et fait des petites cloques !
Attendez !
Et attendez, sous les petites cloques, qu'est-ce qu'il y a ?
On dirait comme des écailles !
Des écailles de dra...
Moi je comprends pas pourquoi les gens ont l'air surpris comme ça.
Je sais pas.
Y a du feu, tu te jettes dans le feu, tu meurs.
Alors on savait pas...
Si c'était le fils du dragon ou pas le fils du dragon.
Apparement c'était pas le fils du dragon.
C'est ma première cérémonie funéraire, genre... officielle.
J'étais super excité à l'idée d'écrire le discours, mais je sais rien sur lui en fait...
Fils de...
On ne sait pas qui.
Tu aimais la soupe de potiron.
Et pourtant, tu es mort.
Tu pensais que brûlé, tu ne pourrais pas...
Et bien brûlé tu es.
Brûlé tu as.
En même temps...
C'est du feu.
On te l'avais... dit.
Si tu étais encore là, je te dirais...
Il est quelle heure ?
La bonne nouvelle c'est que, grâce à Aelys qui est fils de dragon...
On peut avoir le trône de fer.
La mauvaise nouvelle c'est que, comme c'est Aelys le fils de dragon...
C'est lui le chef maintenant.
Moi je suis plus le chef.
Je suis au chômage.
Alors...
Je l'avais dit ou pas ?
Fils de dragon.
Par contre, là je pue hein.